this time around I had gone through a
situation it's funny because you think
that you have your heart broken till you
really have your heart broken et set
down with Elle King to talk about her
new album shake the spirit and surprised
her with a special guest interviewer her
dad
Rob Schneider how are you hey that's my
better side so we're gonna switch seats
so I have some questions for you do you
feel with your second album now that you
finally put the character of the Girl
Scout cookie sales girl and deuce
Bigalow behind you I feel like I'll
never really quite get away from that
your first album and now this is your
second one what was the difference
between like that one and this one
there's a huge difference because I feel
like I gained a lot of notoriety I mean
I had a I had a you know worldwide hit
[Music]
and I feel like I got enough like panic
cojones to be like well I gave you that
I gave you X's and O's let me make them
how I want to make it and they said okay
let me ask you a personal question you
were able to create doing a real you
know a traumatic and powerful time in
your life and do you think there's a
connection to that do you think there's
any accident to it I mean you know I
used to live a little bit more wild
lifestyle and I feel like I just like
created a lot of really bad cycles for
myself that just kind of continued
throughout you know my budding adulthood
but it was for creative chaos or was her
gesture I think I would I feel deeply
what was it I think I just lived a
really chaotic life now I'm making music
in a sober state of mind I didn't make
the album in a simple sober state of
mind but you know that that was still a
very chaotic time but I just don't want
any chaos in my life anymore
[Music]
I remember when you were first doing
this one of my biggest you know fear was
just I love Chris Farley we all loved
him and he just was idolizing the wrong
guy I mean John Belushi was was
brilliant but like you know he was gone
at 32 and so was Chris so I just was
hoping that you would idolize the
Performing side of Janis Joplin I think
a lot a lot of musicians you know
whether it's like chaos in your life or
drugs and alcohol a lot of people think
that they can't make good music or make
good art without it and I'm your daddy
you just have drugs and alcohol from
yeah I know I know I know but you know
that I'm doing so good I know you I'm
proud of you I'm beyond proud
[Music]
thank God I think that the new album is
ridiculously creative in an open and
searingly honest but at the same time to
be able to take that emotion and focus
it into an album in some ways did that
help you lift you out of it yeah it kept
me going because I know how open you are
in your Instagram some of it's hard for
me to watch as you yes your dad loves
you you feel like exposed
I know it's cringe-worthy and it trust
me no no but it is it is it is and like
I understand that very it's painful but
I mean yes it has its it has its its
emotional is what I want to say but at
the same time I know that there are
people in the world that feel like I
have felt in my lowest in my darkest and
my loneliest time and I have this
platform and if I can talk about mental
health issues if I can talk about my
depression if I can talk about things
that I've gone through then maybe it
will make one person hearing it not feel
alone and last year when I was really
just out you know some of my lowest
points I really had no one to turn to
and for some reason I'm just like I'm
just gonna talk about this in the
outpour of support from people and
telling me there in spirit
are getting children now get sharing
their experiences with me of their
trauma or what they've gone through
their depression or just giving me words
of encouragement kept me going now that
I'm doing so much better I feel like
it's almost a responsibility for me to
discuss these things as a comedian
you've lost a lot of friends me growing
up hearing about your friends a lot of
them committed suicide it's a big thing
in comedy you know and so I think it's I
think it's really important for people
to discuss these issues and take the
ickey away from it
so that people can have someone to talk
to or have someone to turn to where do
you go from here I'm older now I've
learned things I've really gone through
life you know I hadn't really gone
through life at 24 25 you know you think
you have but you really don't
what's the first thing comes your mind
would you hope people get when they
listen to I want I want people to know
that it was a very broken and sad person
who made this and at the end of it there
is a message of love that comes through
yourself and that I'm better from it
it's okay to feel broken you can and
will get better that great that's
beautiful I don't know if I've ever been
as honest and stuff I've ever done as
honest as you are and it's been an
inspiration for me to try to get more
honest you know but I'm never gonna open
up myself as much either
I've made a decision well I love you I
love you too that was a nice surprise
I'm proud of you and I can't wait for
the world to embrace it and love it like
I do and like all your fans do and for
you to take it around and enjoy it and
this health of your side that you've got
- I'm really proud and and I just I love
you and I wish you the most success on
your own terms for you okay Thank You
Dylan okay we should start recording
this
[Applause]
[Music]